da ist ein vogel das kind da ist ein
scheiß flugzeug da ist ein scheiß
motorrad band ist denn falsch heute als
maul
das ist mir zu blöd ich gehe jetzt bin
ich hier drin und ich hoffe das geht
jetzt klar ich habe meine haare nicht
gemacht weil ich gerade keinen bock hat
ist mir auch egal
und ja also leute im keine ahnung ob ich
das eben schon gesagt habe auf jeden
fall
es geht heute nicht um ein bestimmtes
thema sondern um eine sache die ich
wirklich unterstützen will die ich geil
finde die wirklich sinn ergibt meiner
macht und deswegen schaut euch bitte das
video ganz an und würde mich freuen und
ich mache jetzt die scheiße warum sind
so viele kinder heute auf jeden fall ist
am 30 06
also vor ich glaube ungefähr zwei wochen
also die aktion gestartet und darüber
möchte ich heute gerne ein ganz bisschen
erzählen und ohne scheiß hört mir bitte
kurz zu so es gibt menschen wie hier in
deutschland es gibt überall auf der welt
menschen die so gut haben wie die
meisten menschen in deutschland
aber es gibt auch sehr viele menschen
die es gar nicht gut haben und das ist
wirklich unvorstellbar gar nicht gut so
etwas könnten sich vorstellen ein
klar jeder weiß es gibt menschen denen
es nicht so gut aber nicht viele wissen
wie scheiße ist denn wirklich wie und
ich glaube das kann man sich als mensch
der jetzt hier wohnen auch gar nicht
vorstellen wie das da sein muss zum teil
ja und seitdem ich mir diese aktion und
der damit verbundenen handy aktion ein
bisschen beschäftigt hat kann ich es
überhaupt nicht verstehen warum so viele
menschen hungern müssen ich mein okay
ich habe jetzt die handy-app schon gold
die heißt cemil der linke zu es in der
beschreibung was noch kurz bevor ihr
euch die möglicherweise donald auf jeden
fall
es geht halt darum ihr könnt in dem ihr
euer paypal konto da keine ahnung was
damit verbindet wirklich ohne scheiß was
schätzt ihr wie viel muss man einem kind
pro tag spenden damit es nicht hungern
muss könnt ihr mal in die kommentare
schreiben was er gedacht hätte
es sind 40 cent das ist wirklich nicht
viel wenn jetzt noch zur schule geht
nicht arbeitet keine ahnung vielleicht
30 euro an taschengeld bekommt im monat
sag ich mal
dann ist es doch auch vollkommen okay
wenn ihr einmal die woche 40
gespendet jetzt denkt wird nicht einfach
so ja es gibt genug menschen jetzt
machen
er ist selber mal was machen ohne scheiß
ich werde viele von euch ich meines euro
böse denken ich jetzt ja das wochen
schon genug
ob ich das jetzt auch noch modern spielt
keine rolle macht einfach mit stellt
euch vor dieses video sehen jetzt mit
der zeit weiß nicht 10 20 30.000
menschen davon machen sich vielleicht
2000 menschen wäre ja auch schon mega
erfolg für mich meiner meinung nach
machen sich diese app und spenden halt
einmal die woche 40 cent wenn ihr
vielleicht ein bisschen mehr geld
überhaupt dann auch jeden tag 40 sind
das ist ja wirklich nicht viel für mich
sehr freuen wenn ihr dort mit macht ein
bisschen was gutes tut und der link dazu
ist in der video beschreibung ist auch
überhaupt kein pollack pech oder so ich
mache das freiwillig könnt ihr auch
gerne in der beschreibung nachlesen oder
irgendwo nach einem product placement
einbindung suchen ist alles weil ich
teilen das gut finde und umsonst ist er
gar nichts bei ja ich glaube dieses
video geht es noch nicht so lange ich
kann noch kurz was ergänzen und zwar
wäre cool wenn ihr das auch noch
anhalten wird von mir der macht bei
einem contest mit dem test ist dass ich
weiß nicht vielleicht kennt ihr 109 von
euch
und zwar geht es halt darum eine video
hochzuladen was wir wirklich gut ist und
der gewinner fliegt ab er wollte noch
ein paar klicks ein paar likes und ich
würde mich freunde sagen kumpel von mir
wer megageil der link videos auch und in
der video beschreibung klickt einfach
mal drauf schaut euch das video ganz
anders der positive bewertung da bin ich
persönlich auch sehr freuen
und das war es von mir unterstützt sind
ein bisschen trentl
wir sehen uns morgen wieder morgens
montag der kopfhaut video mit coolen
hoffe ich mal 15 uhr einschalten